uh yes Wilfred the um this particular
issue is a relatively a small one it's
almost certainly an accident a flight
from Pakistan via Roman into Heathrow
was detected with some Uranium on board
some scrap metal I have to say if that
was terrorists trying to bring it in
they would bring it into the one place
in the UK that would be bound to catch
it I mean Heathrow is the one place
where uranium will always be detected so
that almost rules it out the point about
uranium is that the uh the the the
Heathrow scanners would immediately pick
up any toxic uranium because uranium
natural uraniums all around us so known
as uranium 238 it's actually isotope and
uranium-238 is 99 what it is uranium 238
but one percent of it is something
different one percent of it is
um partly that is three quarters at one
percent 0.7 of it is uranium two three
five which is the isotope which is
fissionable and if you can extract the
uranium-235 from it you can start to do
something with it and this is what it
looks like it gets extracted as uranium
oxide sometimes known as yellow cake and
then it is enriched so you're trying to
enrich the 0.7 percent in natural
uranium to make it one percent two
percent five percent uh uranium two
three five and when it's five percent
uranium two three five or something like
that you can use it as fuel which would
be a in this case it would be
um uranium dioxide and that sort of
isotope can be made into fuel pellets
and used to power a nuclear reactor and
even uranium used in hospitals is
degraded uranium from research reactors
or power reactors and so on So You Keep
On enriching it and enrichment is a very
complex process not many countries can
actually do it efficiently requires lots
and lots of centrifuges spinning away in
a great Cascade but if you keep
enriching if you enrich it to say 20
uranium two three five then that's good
enough for nuclear submarine power for
powering aircraft carriers for powering
icebreakers any ships big ships that
need lots of power so at any given time
there are about 200 ships in the world
powered by nuclear reactors and if you
keep on enriching to 90 percent uranium
235 then that is Bomb grade material
that gives you enough to make a nuclear
bomb now it's quite difficult then to
make it work but nevertheless
uranium-235 and 90 enrichment is
nuclear-powered material and the point
about all of this
is that uranium-235 is the useful part
of natural uranium which is around us
all the time is completely harmless but
once you begin to deal with uranium-235
it has a half-life a half-life of 700
million years so once you begin to
manipulate natural uranium uranium-238
to the good stuff that you can use for
all sorts of purposes uranium-235 you've
got to live with it forever and that
means it will always always be some sort
of a security problem